the Black Sea initiative enabled the
safe export of some 33 million metric
tons of foodstuffs from three Ukrainian
ports including more than 750 000 metric
tons of wheat transported by wfp helping
to relieve hunger in Afghanistan the
Horn of Africa and Yemen
the initiative helped bring down Global
food prices
the memorandum of understanding on
Russian food and fertilizer exports also
delivered concrete results over the past
year
as the Secretary General stated this
morning the decision of the Russian
Federation to terminate the Black Sea
initiative will strike a blow to people
in need everywhere ukrainians are
Russians principal victims but this war
is also harming the poor and the
vulnerable across the world particularly
in Africa in Asia and in Latin America
Energy prices rocketed by 20 worldwide
last year almost doubling Global
inflation from 4.7 to 8.7 percent
World Food Supplies have fallen sharply
Ukrainian food exports Maize barley or
wheat have plummeted by more than 40
percent with catastrophic consequences
for sub uh Saharan Africa which relies
on these supplies after all the
spillover effect of this needless War
are profound just look at the harm
Russia has done to the world's food
supply by weaponizing food Russia has
exacerbated the global food security
crisis a crisis that disproportionately
impacts people in the Middle East and
Africa and today in another Act of
Cruelty Russia suspended its
participation in the Black Sea brain
initiative this Arrangement has brought
stability to Global Food Markets and
lowered food prices for all it is
bolstered the world food programs
humanitarian work in places like
Afghanistan Somalia and Yemen and
according to the U.N nearly two-thirds
of the wheat exported through this
Arrangement has gone to developing
countries Russia put mostly nations in
Asia and Africa at risk of facing uh
increasing food prices
and hunger
this must stop
and now you know we we have we all have
a headache we have to solve another yet
another problem
created by Russia
and I emphasized to the Secretary
General and I'm also making this
emphasis in all other conversations that
if we have the political will we will
find the way out
so in the next hours and days they will
be very intensive consultations at all
levels
to find a solution
to this immense problem that Russia has
created for the world the attack on the
Kirsch Bridge civilian infrastructure
was that a legitimate Target
who what makes you believe that Carriage
Bridge is a civilian infrastructure
given that it is mainly used to supply
Russian army in the occupied Crimea and
in the south of Ukraine with ammunition
uh Fuel and other military equipment
necessary for the Russian army to
continue its war of aggression against
against Ukraine not every bridge is
civilian by definition and this
particular Bridge first it was built
illegally it exists beyond the law and
we should always remember that and
second it is mainly used for military
purposes and we should consider it as
such